sopra d'enquêté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis enfin je suis aveugle
qui est avec nous l'album phoenix et de
la bombe encore c'est de la bombe merci
d'être avec nous merci d'être là c'est
le père noël qui chante un nom
merci chauprade être avec nous on va
faire une bataille tous connaissaient la
bataille savez comme dans la bataille
normal avec les cartes comme ça eh bien
on va faire une bataille tous les deux
le problème c'est que si vous perdez
vous prenez un verre d'eau si je perds
je prends un verre d'eau et puis ça ira
de plus en plus loin comme ça il ya des
verts de plus en plus loin précisé
prendre un verre d'eau ça veut dire
boire se jeter donc regarder vous allez
voir vous allez comprendre de tout tout
de suite jingle fait partie on a des
cartes vous avez ici
vauvert ça veut dire que si vous perdez
la première bataille tac c'est pour vous
attention si on a la même carte si la
bataille on peut prendre n'importe
lequel
d'accord sur celui qui gagne mais est ce
qu'on va crescendo savez bien où
commencer par exactement on va le gendre
pandraud de commencer par ça n'aura
banon sinon et il ya des cartes aux
bonus
ok nabila ou et dorin d'accord ça me
doivent nous remplacer un panda maintien
quant aux pratiques alors attention vous
voulez coupé jeu coupal et j'ai coupé
parce que comme ça vous allez voir qu'il
n'ya pas de tri ya pas de triche dame de
coeur j'ai pas mal
je suis pas mal des serviettes et savez
on a une telle petite production
allez-y soprano devra se battre ici on
est débouté dépouilles des boutons d
homère d'armes en direct déjà ah bah oui
bah oui c'est ça attends je pense avoir
fait boire fait de voir il ya une hausse
est de piques à la la la la moue sopra
non bon se promener là joueurs médecin
hiver c'est rien du tout y aura mon tir
[Applaudissements]
vers 9h12 l'année prochaine ça va faire
dix ans d'albums solo a commencé j'avais
12 ans coiffeur 6 mai bricole pas
j'avais 15 ans et ouais tu vois et mon
avec mon groupe les psy4 de la rime
amazon avait 12 ans c'est ça qui
cartonne aussi on et illégaux in town et
a laissé ça c'est la non merci au joker
et nora justice mais je lui mettrai
jamais décisif alors allons-y maintenant
retirer la carte donc peut-être que
peut-être que vous avez la carte à
désirer la carte dès que c'est la vie la
haye un as et n'a pas migré vers l'asie
ah non je tire une carte le roi en plus
il était pas mal mais je ne peux pas
alors pourquoi vous pouvez pas changer
très chaud écoutez alors un tout petit
vous voulez à tout prix mais b à bb et
bb- allez-y alors tu es prête
simon gillham était devant ou derrière
s'il vous plaît
sopra est ce que tu me quittes je chante
je suis en feu façon naturelle en bonne
voie tu m'as tu peux essayer
quelle est la première arrêté
non
je connais ce n'est que la première
phrase mais cela fait plutôt bien comme
zinedine zidane face à l'équipe du
brésil suis un peu ce soir j'ai par la
suite ce serait donner des glaçons aussi
notre truc je vais juste testé jeudi
jeffrey encore plus loin si je sais on
voit le match et cyril ont fait à la
bien pour les mecs en bas des blocs on
le fait à la bien aimée qui sont épais
on fait la guerre familles sains comme
les sopranos et avec qui je connais moi
là le corps humain attention on fait la
dernière que l'an dernier mais leurs
actes mais cependant à l'est la force
pas
non c'est non non ont été les vôtres
hawks doit rentrer mais je comprends
mais vous êtes vous êtes parent dont ils
nous avaient une chance de dégâts ces
intrigues de creech [ __ ] attention
bataille
on la refait
[Applaudissements]
un roi
non non c'est ce côté se maintiennent
aux côtés aménagé réaménager ce manque
d'allant mais j'ai cliqué quelque chose
alors la bataille à la carte qui recoupe
d'accord soit le sahara calaisis livre
le 5 à 10 on sait jamais à me voir moi
je le prends
[Applaudissements]
vous savez quoi
c'est pour moi c'est cadeau
m
[Applaudissements]